welcome to this video round for coverage
of the open international bavarian
championships ya round phone i had the
big game bought one of the tournament
playing the number one seed so the best
possible draw that you can get i always
want the best possible opposition it's
just the reason why you play this kind
of tournaments and yeah but who is this
guy it's not one of the very well known
players I guess rant if I pronounces
correctly rant Malcolm young and he's
some somewhat known to German players
maybe because he lives in Berlin Germany
and is a training partner for Levon
Aronian so he is sometimes his place in
the german bundesliga as well and
therefore might be known to some some
people he recently has some yeah has
some gained lots of rating points he's
on 2678 now so very close somewhat close
to the 2700 berries like number 70 or
something in the world yeah so what to
play against such a guy the good thing
is I have white which is helpful I feel
against very strong opposition the bad
thing was when I looked at his opening
repertoire that it didn't really give me
any clear indication of what he will
play and I relatively quickly um
discarded the idea to play 1d form
because it sometimes placed the green
felt and if you watch my blitz games you
might know that I play some weird stuff
against the green felt sometimes I play
stuff like that and I really don't
really don't want to play this kind of
stuff against a very strong player who
probably knows it better than I do
I sometimes play alternatively against
the Greenfeld stuff like this which is
more solid but well this is the absolute
favorite variation of aronia at least it
was for a number of years so mikumi on
will know it inside out so I should I
shouldn't do that simply not deform so i
went with nida 3 they're just mostly an
entire gruene phone off yeah he played
d5 and I was a little bit surprised that
he played a Queens gambit declined and
it's part of his repertoire but the the
whole of the whole opening is while
being very solid not very suitable to
win with black and I was expecting
especially here I was expecting
something a little bit yeah a little bit
sharper for example c6 now the semi slob
or maybe Bishop before the Rogo's in he
played night bd7 however and after
Bishop g5 he expected c6 again maybe for
Cambridge Springs or something he played
Bishop e7 so this is the the uber
classic I like from back from Kappa
blanca and Lacan um alle kind III
castles the the the total like the
dinosaur form of the Queens gambit
declined and it is in fact not such a
bad line there are interesting ways if
in fact for black to play that however
this whole line has one drawback from a
practical point of view it is difficult
to win against a specific variation that
white can play and I was surprised by
that I couldn't prepare anything but I
knew that the odd move Quincy to buy
called the Rubenstein variation yet
another Rubenstein variation and you
that this is very difficult for black to
play for wind because he now has
basically two alternatives simplifying
to a very very em dau position or
accepting a disadvantage and he did the
simplifying option yeah what I mean is
that black definitely wants to play c5
now or one move later and any other
option that is more fighting let's say
let's say you play something like b6 for
example after that I can transpose to a
Queens gambit declined exchange in a
very favorable form something like this
is very nice for wide with F for castles
you are setting up this typical
pillsbury information there's also very
famous game by Kasparov played against
Alexander boyarsky in the candidates
matches of 1983 i think it was um where
Kasparov won a very nice game against by
offski so this is well known and to be
avoided but like even if you want to
play for Windows is very risky he went
with age 6 I played Bishop h4 in fact
here White has a funny alternative in
the capture on d5 it looks crazy but
light can play this piece sacrifice with
unclear consequences it's an interesting
line but without any without preparing
this beforehand I don't want to play a
piece down after 10 moves against the
2700 player so I did not do that I knew
that it exists and I might do it in
other circumstances but but not here I
just went Bishop h4 especially knowing
that here black will definitely go see 5
and move like c6 for example the the
very old-fashioned
to play is answered by luke t 1 which
sets up this typical opposition by Queen
and and rook and this is very tough for
black to to equalize also note that if
like tries something like that this
typical maneuver developed by Kappa
Blanca I now can play them Bishop to g3
I don't need to trade necessarily and
this is also nice for white I just have
a better center yeah which means to make
to come to the point black must play c5
yeah and after that I'm going to take
night takes see takes d4 as an
alternative also very solid and equal
but very boring yeah he went with the
nitrate takes take cm and that take here
yeah and after this we see that we have
two sets of minor pieces traded black
has an isolated pawn and he does not
have any great activity for the porn so
it's this a better position for white
hmm maybe very slightly vary vary
slightly but blackest is fairly solid
especially if he is content with debt
equality he can after Bishop e2 which
are played he can play with Bishop to g4
96 intending d4 and as I think can
easily be very very very equal but of
course he wanted to do something and not
play this to a total debt equality if he
tried 94 and Bishop f5 okay went 90 for
Bishop back Bishop d3 group c 8 22 yeah
I mean here I was I was of course very
satisfied with the position it is a
total aesthetic position absolute
no um you have big dynamic things going
on I have a excellent night an excellent
night that blockades his miss iqp and
he's very far away from any sort of
attack on my king or whatever so it's
just exactly where you want to be
against a strong opponent yeah he tried
to look c5 and I don't mind trading
route see one group c 8 yeah and here i
had um yeah yeah i just saw what what
happened the next couple of moves and
went for it I mean and you need to be
honest with yourself a draw and the game
is perfectly fine and I did not really
see anything great that I can do so I
went I went for the trades and this yeah
just swept us just just trade everything
off and we shouldn't underestimate the
fact that black has an isolated queen
porn so I still entertained some hopes
of maybe just being a little bit better
um it in fact instead of rupee one I
could have played rugby one which is a
little bit better just you are not
trading everything here white has a
slight advantage and the same applies in
the game after Roxy when he played queen
before here I can also play rookie one
with the slight advantage but I am
honest I just wanted to play this as
safe as possible and and I made a
miscalculation I took on e4 here with
the bishop um which is not a bad move
really but it is followed up with a bad
continuation he took with the bishop my
idea was to with this straight to at the
end establish this great knight on d4
witches unchallengeable on d4 against a
bad bishop only for that is basically
pointing into thin air of course I have
a coordination problem I cannot play
with 94 obviously due to this and black
is also sometimes threatening to take
be three week back rank the problem is I
made a mistake now what I should do is I
should play Queen to d1 and after that I
have no problems whatsoever the idea is
to later get the night before I did to
cover the rook my idea and this was
planned a couple of moves ago however
was to play not Queen d1 but to play
every and I played that this however has
a big drawback I actually thought that
I'm better here rook takes Knight takes
and here thought wow isn't this a great
position he has to move the bishop now
somewhere and I go a three he plays
whatever let's say here and I go to d2
and then I regrouped the night with a
fantastic position yeah on Knight to c3
yeah fantastic is a little bit little
bit much but it's something that you
will never ever lose they are not not
not even against Magnus Carlsen or God
or whatever it's just what you what you
want to have you can even try to win for
ages um I was really enthusiastic yeah
what what's a great position but then it
turned all of course well this this is
this guy is no no dummy he he played the
move Bishop c2 and this was very
embarrassing because I hadn't seen this
before hand at all yeah tactics tactics
tactics I cannot take it well this is
also not good I cannot take it because
of checkmate hmm very embarrassing and
the problem is it just it takes the pawn
yeah and I have no other way to defend
defend the porn then to advance it so I
needed to play be three yeah and this is
not a move that you want to play it
weakens the dark squares enormously
stuff like this
and at the moment really my night on c1
is not coordinated at all with my queen
and the whole camp it's a matter of some
coordination if I get the night
magically to d4 I'm in great shape but
at the moment I don't really call in a
dwell this position is it's not ammonius
and I actually believe that the most
critical point in the whole game for me
is around here because it's possible
that maybe here with more precise plane
he could have post me a much much more
serious problems on the computer for a
for example wants to play Bishop to be
one here the idea being that it is
difficult after this move um yet to
suggest anything great for wide it's
almost zoosk one I don't really have
anything great um during the game when
he was thinking about his move I was
thinking if he goes here I Oh probably
just play the King up to have to maybe
this is a possible continuation
sometimes yeah move the King up and
after the check here if he gives a check
just drop back but here he can play
deform and this is comparable to the
game where he went d 4 immediately but
this seems a little bit more tricky um
it is some it is very annoying the whole
thing if you look at this for example
this is a terrible position and all was
in zoosk run here yeah my night is
dominated and really really awful all
the consequence of this tactical shot
with Bishop see to that I missed I guess
something like this Bishop be one move
was a chance for black dude to put more
pressure on he played deform and after
d4 I had King f2 and now of course he
does not have the check here and my idea
is to just take and play Queen III em
with a in okay position or um yeah at
least something that I can hold he now
took Queen takes check and back to g1
and this is far better coordinated than
in the other lines my queen is just more
active it looks here it covers this yeah
he tried b6 yeah well a seven was not
hanging but at some point it will hang
so this just makes sense Queen c3 yeah I
know it's not attacking the bishop still
that's the the main threat but the Queen
Esther ball positioned here I went with
this setup yeah and here I was pretty
confident that the worst is over I was
really shocked when he got this Bishop
see to move in but here I was pretty
confident that it's totally equal um
after some moves here I actually offered
to draw which i rarely do to be honest
if I'm a huge underdog in a game rating
wise I normally don't offer draws at all
because it's sort of yeah kind of clear
that the higher rated player tries to
win and if he feels like okay I cannot
win anymore or Joy's okay he will offer
himself but I really thought that okay
this is so equal that I can I can't
really offer a draw but but she declined
and continued nothing that really
surprised me I was just thinking okay
let's let's offer a draw and see what
what comes okay he continued um there is
really no no big reason for that despite
the 200 something points that he has on
me um yeah it does not really need to be
explain that much yeah I mean the thing
is it's it's almost a fortress right I
have the Queen rb2 I cover oops that's a
bit much I cover a three I cover the
second-ranked and he does not even have
a check so I can just basically sit
tight and wait if he comes up with any
idea you only need to be a little bit
alert that you don't allow something and
I didn't allow anything next couple of
moves just basically shuffling around
but don't underestimate the the
situation it's not like you can play all
our moves instant you still have to
check if there are some little ideas
that that come up because well you know
the situation when you are the stronger
player you keep doing low things and
sometimes the weaker player just just
breaks down at some point so we
continued for quite a while in this in
this vein and now we our move 50 it's
important in the time control for this
tournament was 90 minutes for fraud he
moves and then additional 30 minutes
after move 40 with 30 second increment
for the whole from of one so this means
that here on move 50 we were like on 15
minutes each and increment and the
further cause of the game was some it
was not much happening I need to be
honest here the further cause of the
game was like this and around here we
were we both had a little bit more than
increment like two or three minutes and
I actually I'd started to get a little
bit optimistic here because well okay I
have gained a little bit of space there
k this can also be weakness but yeah
there are some ideas that white has I
mean night to e4 is an idea going to f6
I mean I really didn't see a reason why
I should be
any worse here and maybe a yeah maybe I
can do something in this position
especially after he played be five I was
thinking that there are now lots of
situations that are actually favorable
for what if I manage to get Queens
traded yeah just think about this if
queens are off I have the clearly better
hand game he's got a pawn on a light
squares with a light squared Bishop I
have the more active King the king is
only three in the middle of the board
but it is safe due to this great night
which defends it also the reason why he
went b5 he wants to activate this bishop
and attack my night so too to be honest
I was thinking that well maybe he's
doing um he's maybe it's doing some
things that yeah are actually not
helpful for his position went here and
age five mmhmm yeah my original
intention of course here was to play g5
but after that he is all of a sudden it
gets his queen IAM and that's not
looking good so I went age five and
after Queen h2 I took yeah um if he
takes he opens up his King position and
maybe Queen c2 is a move that will come
later I'm hard for him to avoid the
Queen trade and Queen traits are good
for me the age five porn is not a
weakness and I have ideas to attack for
example a seven with my night and wind
upon yeah this is why he went queen age
two and I took and went kingi for ya
activating the king my king is a good
pizza and I intend to play Queen at four
here I was definitely trying to do to
get more than a draw I was thinking okay
why not i mean my king is more active
and lots of configurations are good for
me objectively however it is still very
much equal the computers basically on 0
time and sometimes give 0.14 one side
but it's very equal yeah he went here
Queen activated check back and he pushed
the King back okay 23 based on the fact
that an end game is better for me due to
my active pieces and the weakness of
this pawn that pawn will easily fall if
we trade Queens yeah he avoided the
trade and I went f4 okay and now the
next possible idea is to at some point
maybe play Queen e5 getting a passer of
course mmm tricky business he has an
aged porn as well ok Wendy should be six
funny defensive move but good one the
tech CM ok when g5 and now he took the
pawn yeah around here we were playing
with our side 30 seconds increment we
didn't have any more time um h5 was also
possible but is a risky move of calcium
this is a possible asset for black but
it's a risky business to keep white pawn
structure intact I even have Queenie 5
which is very hard to assess um I think
it was a good decision for him to take
Bishop f7 yeah and now I'm regrouping
Knight to f3 and King here my king is
secure now protected by a queen and
night and what I want to do is I want to
get some attack against the king with
the combined force of night and queen if
I'm able to generate some attack on his
King I might get to the situation where
I can favorably trade and then in wait
with my king this was the winning plan
so King g8 King here and centralizing
yeah why does in good shape and all
those moves are perfectly okay I check
this afterwards with the engine Queenie
six green c7 yeah gaining space and
maybe getting in 95 King g8 king g3 and
now I'm ready to play 95 he played King
f8 and with king of 80 offered to draw
we are now unmoved 78 78 and this was
the final game of this round we were the
only people playing left in this big big
tournament hall and many spectators
around the bottom and he offered the
draw here but I really wanted to win now
I mean it's clear that white is the one
pushing and accepting a draw is just a
very chicken behavior so it was clear
that I should decline um and I really
thought that I'm much better here it
seems that the computer is not agreeing
and it says it is totally equal but I
absolutely must decline because from a
practical point of view this position is
much better for white much easier for
wide to play 95 is good you should be
eight yeah and the next two moves I
think are just not very ah not very much
to the point um if you analyze it with
the engine it says equal all the time
but this is only half of the truth the
thing is that the night is some very
uncomfortable piece to play against with
the somewhat open King and little time
on the clock what I want to do is really
or what I should try form is something
that yeah it keeps night and Queen on
the board and I should sort of try to
alternate threats and shuffle around a
little bit and keep the situation on
bored with no threats and what I'm doing
now check and here and it looks like a
good idea it still looks like a good
idea to me but he has the move Bishop d7
he defended this just very nicely he has
Bishop d7 and here the problem is that
yeah it moves like this for example it's
not leading anywhere I can he can go
here and i have no check here and he is
threatening something very substantial
and okay if i trade him there's simply
nothing happening um yeah the check also
looks nice but hmm he just moved the
king and there is no continuation I
don't even have a check to follow up and
again he has counter play like this
especially queen is shreya the problem
yeah I didn't see anything here any
continuation and then um yeah I really
didn't know what to do and then I
spotted with like five seconds on the
clock I spotted this move and went for
it which was a little bit of a gamble
because I couldn't really evaluate it
properly yeah okay and threatening
Knight f6 oh he has to take it check and
this and I was seeing that he cannot
activate his King after King e6 because
i have Knight f6 followed up by this and
when I saw that I saw okay covered
covered covered covered so I probably um
don't risk anything much um and it still
is possible to do something for white
because all his pawns on light squares
and however it turned out that here
there is nothing nothing going on he can
draw this quite quite easily Bishop g2
94 intending 95 and but he has this move
that keeps the whole thing together
I still have to be a little bit cautious
and move like this for example of
languages look at this all of a sudden
he has this activation idea so I must be
a must be careful that he's not all of a
sudden activates his stuff so i went to
you three here and King you form yeah
keeping the fifth-ranked under control
Bishop e7 King before King e6 we
shuffled the BTM I still tried to win
king f4 but should be seven them there
is no way forward we all move 93 now and
yeah I can cut this short we shuffled a
bit and here with moved 100 kingdom for
move 100 we agree tech to draw because
here we just it is just basically a
repetition of moves forever um yeah and
an epic fight of 100 moves it probably
does not look very young very thrilling
if you now see the game but I can assure
you that it was a very exhausting
experience to play 100 moves against
someone where you know that he won't
miss much it was of course fun to
decline the draw but it was a little bit
a little bit disappointed that that when
when I got to this situation that I have
to basically a trade Quincy and cannot
torch him a little bit with with Queens
and and night against the king it was a
little bit disappointing I think them
yeah for black I think probably the key
point was when I had overlooked this
Bishop situ resource here maybe some
better mood order gives him a better
chances to win the way it went in the
game
this this this type of position really
was just totally equal and he he never
got got anywhere near something like a
win all in all a little bit of a
surprising opening choice he's a very
solid and technical player so there is
some some logic behind it but it's just
a little bit a little bit dull to try to
get a win a game um with black yeah so
okay a good result of course i was very
satisfied that that I didn't lose the
game right after the game I must admit I
was slightly disappointed because I
thought that with Queen and and night
around here I really had a big advantage
I thought but this is not justified the
computer just defends this mercilessly
but if for a practical point of view
this is a very very uncomfortable
situation for black I could have
certainly made life more difficult for
him but I couldn't I couldn't manage
really especially with just increment on
the clock yeah I hope you enjoyed the
game anyway it was a really long affair
but I hope some of the tension that was
in the game yeah was conveyed in the
video it's very hard to to do when you
when you're not not there it was a very
tense game the last 20 30 minutes we
were the only guys playing in the hole
hole and so this is always something
special okay hope you enjoyed it thanks
for watching